all right let's uh let's let's there we
go here we go
[Music]
here we go all right so we have Bingo
cards I'm gonna happen
um and we're gonna be checking off
because we did last time and actually
Lauren's the only one drinking
[Music]
I have
soul of the nation oh gosh
it's like the name of the speech it is
do I get that one already
yeah that counts but he's repeating that
he did that the first time around oh
here he goes here he comes you ready
I'm scared
my fellow Americans oh no he already
can't talk
wait is coughing on here was that an
action I speak to you tonight
from sacred ground in America
Independence Hall in Philadelphia
Pennsylvania
this is where America made its
Declaration of Independence to the world
more than two centuries ago with an idea
hello among nations holy cow he's three
minutes late so I get starts late
create it equal
this is where the United States
Constitution was written and debated
this is where we set in motion
the most
extraordinary experiment of
self-government the world has ever known
what you're taking away from us with
three simple words no we the people we
the people
these two documents and the idea is they
embody
equality and democracy
are the rock upon which this nation is
built
there how we became the greatest nation
on Earth
there why
for more than two centuries America has
been a beacon to the world yeah yeah
come on come on
well as I stand here tonight
equality and democracy are under assault
by your Administration to ourselves no
favor to pretend otherwise
so tonight
I've come to this place where it all
began
to speak as plainly as I can but you
haven't started the nation yeah come on
guys about the threats we Face let's go
the threats about the power we have in
our own hands I hear the Liberty Bell
crackers
about the incredible future
the lies in front of us if only we
choose it
must never forget
We the People
are the true Heirs of the American
experiment okay that began more than two
centuries ago
the propaganda yeah
the flame of Liberty if he's given this
exact speech here 400 times we just
forget it
Flame
that lit our way through abolition and
you're blowing out he's literally
suffraged yeah I know come on world wars
no he's setting the stage this is a a
propaganda
Burns you know get everybody excited
about it I'm the real Patriots
that is more prosperous
free and just
that is the work of my presidency this
is cultural appropriation of Real
Americans I believe now with my whole
soul oh Soul first ah come on you must
be honest with each other right with
ourselves
[Laughter]
which is not normal
Donald Trump Republicans represented
extremism that threatens the very
foundations Trump is falling higher than
Biden right now I want to be very clear
right clear up front
I wonder if they had an Applause
Republicans
Mega Republicans
never even braces their extreme ideology
should yeah it's like Cheney or Lynn
Cheney because I was able to work with
these mainstream Republicans
Main Street but there's no question he
means rhinos as a Republican party today
by Donald Trump and the Maggie
Republicans
and that is a threat to this country
this is crazy stuff these are hard
things this is very frightening
seriously but I'm an American Civil War
level rhetoric from the president yeah
it's not a president of red America blue
America what do you mean red America
blue America are you going to give that
speech that Obama
the American people my duty to level
with you to tell the truth no matter how
difficult well then talk about your
son's laptop
and here in my view is what is true
Mighty Republicans do not respect the
Constitution they do not believe in the
rule of law they do not recognize the
will of the people hey well the people I
would have refused to accept the results
of a free election
and they're working right now
as I speak in state after state
to give power to decide elections in
America to partisans and cronies
empowering elections this is what you've
been doing this is the president using
the White House to campaign to deliver a
campaign speech to take this country
backwards what is that law that is there
is some law I don't know what it is
there's a where there is no right to
choose
political violence
that are a threat what did Christine uh
what's her name Maxine Waters what did
Schumer say after the Roe versus Wade
what are you talking about the very soul
of what they look at the mob the storm
the United States capital on January 6
January 6th brutally testing law
enforcement do I have that one not as
insurrectionist oh Insurrection oh it's
an Insurrection of our democracy but
they're looking as Patriots
after the 2020 election saying Trump
didn't as preparation
for the 2022 and 2024 elections is that
protesters they're trying yeah
everything's last time to nullify the
votes of 81 million people
this time
they're determined to succeed in
thwarting the will of the people you
know listen that's why Joey respect to
conservatives Joey I got to tell you
something George tell him Michael
ludding
has called Trump an extreme maggot
Republicans quote a clear and present
danger to our democracy
but while the threat to American
democracy is real
I want to say as clearly as we can
we are not powerless
in the face of these threats
we are not bystanders in this ongoing
attack on democracy
there are far more Americans
far more Americans
remember every from every background of
belief to reject the extreme mag
ideology he's not just those that accept
people who were on January 6th anymore
he's saying oh yeah
it's in our hands yours setting the
nation again to stop the assault on
American democracy vice president I've
ever heard the assault of American
democracy Reflection Point the
Democratic party is a Marxist cultural
revolution that you're determined to
shut up you're the one that's been
shaping everything you guys have changed
the election
lawsuit what's doing what fascism is to
move forward Robert how old is backwards
you want the truth yeah to build the
future have you ever heard a president
give a speech like a nation of Hope and
unity and optimism I haven't heard a
Democratic party do this I haven't heard
politicians do Darkness
Republicans they Embrace anger
they thrive on chaos
they live not in the light of truth but
in the shadow of Lies what are you
talking about Joe propaganda
what lies Joe we can choose a better
path Joe whis Corn Pop the guy the guy
who claims he drives an 18-wheeler yeah
oh no joke Joe
and we're on that who wrote the speech
Joe
I know this nation
I know you the American people
I know your courage
I know your hearts
and I know our history
Joe we do not reject it
this is a nation that believes in the
rule of law
what happened for two years as the riots
were happening what happened to law
where did you respect the police
officers you guys didn't say anything
Joe we do not deny it
and this is a nation
that rejects violence as a political
tool that's what you did with antifa and
BLM and bailed them out thank you very
much the beliefs and honesty and decency
How Could You Lie like this tell us the
truth and then we can respect you from
Liberty justice for all hope
possibilities we are still at our core a
democracy
and yet we're a republic in the
constitutional republic yeah
constitutional republic history tells us
that's awkward the blind loyalty to a
single leader and a willingness to
engage in political violence is fatal to
democracy
for a long time
we've told ourselves that American
democracy is guaranteed he's saying a
lot of nothing but it's not he is
defended
period protected he's going to make a
turn each and every one of us he's
setting it up darker that's why the
numbers
74 million voters yep
this is
you know and he's riling up I would have
told him if I would have said four years
ago in front extremist president in 2022
we give a speech pursuit of power
calling half the nation
Democrats Independents mainstream
Republicans
we must be stronger more determined and
more committed to saving Americans This
is the type of stuff they used to do
behind closed doors this is the basket
of the deplorable comment but as a
20-minute Primetime speech We the People
The Quiet part is that the plan 20
minutes anyone well because I can't
stand
this feels like an abusive relationship
around us you know we also have to watch
McCarthy's all oh yeah that's because we
could criticize that if they don't
violence
in this country
see it's only violence if it's not doing
it it was not BLM doing it that doesn't
count if you walk in the wrong way there
is no place for political violence in
America period then why are you doing it
with her the Looting and the antifa our
inner cities have violence what are you
doing defunding the police what about to
defund the police what about fentanyl
the violence that's pouring in because
of the Border joke this isn't even true
we've seen election officials
but no one was killed no officers can
you believe it FBI agent oh FBI just
doing their job as directed facing
threats what about the Supreme Court
Justices Joe from their own Supreme
Court Justices Joe on top of that aren't
they citizens public figures today
yesterday and the day before predicting
and all the calling for Mass violence
and writing for Maxine Waters and for
Schumer when we had a decision
is dangerous it's against the rule of
law
and we the people must say this is not
who we are it's their democracy it's not
ours how many times has he talked about
violence
gentlemen the closed caption is ahead of
him
pro-insurrectionist for those that are
watching at home look at the closed
caption that it shows it before he says
it we can't allow violence to be
normalized in this country it's wrong
but you did that with it black lives
matter jokes with with all the morals
there were no mega people rioting the
streets Joe for two years
we can't let them they were sick of
having three years of what happened in
America and the government did nothing
so they went to the Capitol to protest
of what they saw was the destruction of
our constitution in a democracy I
believe in the give and take of politics
and disagreement and debate and dissent
no you don't no you're a big complicated
because seriously when they spent yes
but democracy endures only if we the
people we respect the guard rails of the
Republic only if
We the People accept the results of free
and fair elections is crime happening
America that he's not addressed politics
it's basically that is
how do you think they've got the
captions
it could be both yeah they'll put out
this year yeah or they were cheated
and that's where the Maggie Republicans
are today he's acting like none of us
existed between 2016 and 2020. we're
they don't understand
patriotic America knows that for three
years Schiff and Schumer and Pelosi had
Russian collusion that was a false FBI
government
um
bureaucratic attack on the presidency of
the United States that's the
Insurrection Joe
to respect the rule of law and the
institutions that were set up in this
chamber institutions
we respect our legitimate political
differences
I will not stand by and watch you just
gave a 15-minute speech disrespected
wild conspiracy and baseless
evidence-free claims of fraud I will not
Stand By and Watch elections in this
country stolen by people who simply
refuse to accept the projection the
project they've been doing it since
Kennedy when Kennedy was losing they
went to Sam John Connor and they said we
need votes and that's how they beat
Nixon and have your vote count it
and be taken from you and the American
people
look
as your president I will defend our
democracy with every fiber of my being
and I'm asking every American to join me
he keeps repeating this it's so strange
and you know they say Trump is the one
who's obsessed with the elections with
you know America's also made the
greatest progress they're just as
obsessed some of our darkest moments
you're the protesters
I believe we can and must do that again
if there's some fjb channels we are
we're there yeah Maggie Republicans
looking Americans see Carnage and
darkness and despair we've been on the
streets later in life go go to Los
Angeles in the homeless walk around with
your nice sunglasses and see if somebody
comes and rips them off
an America with an unlimited future
an American is about to take off
I hope you see it as well just look
around aside from it being like okay
it's a propaganda faster it's stronger
than any other imagination in the world
we have more to go this amazing economy
my friends
so we passed the biggest infrastructure
investment since president Dwight D
Eisenhower and we've now embarked a
decade of rebuilding the nation's roads
Bridges highways porch Water Systems
high-speed internet Railroad
I believe we can make America safer so
we passed the most significant gun
safety law since President Clinton
I believe I believe that the district
attorneys in major cities are letting
criminals out how are we safely Joe the
world to making prescription drugs and
health care more affordable so we passed
the most significant Health Care reform
since President Obama
Care Act
perfect
[Applause]
and I believe to create
we could create a clean energy future
and save the planet
so we passed the most important climate
initiative ever ever ever and we'll go
back to you in your cars between four
and seven exactly don't water your lawn
and we'll be using candles in a few
years tell us nothing can get done
but they're wrong
there is not a single thing America
cannot do not a single thing beyond our
capacity he's just campaign I hope
America can vote you out of office is
what I hope well we're proving that
America no matter how long it's looking
good already that's why he's doing this
they're desperate you think so
absolutely you look at the Maga
Republicans who are winning and that's
what they're scared of the establishment
I know the last year a few years have
been tough I hope so but today I think
so Cove would no longer controls Our
Lives
more Americans are working than ever
covet never controls businesses are
growing our schools are open
millions of Americans have been lifted
out of poverty let's go Brandon Village
well now get what they deserve for their
families in the compassion compensation
this is American manufacturers come
alive across the Heartland the future
will be all want to root for someone
right we want to root for people but
when you you're demonizing like Hillary
Clinton did with baskets of deplorables
across this country that have a
different ideology than the Marxist left
gun violence oh Charlottesville we can't
see the light on here though light is
now visible that's how I know he's
collectible guys
not only in words but in actions actions
for you for your children for your
grandchildren for screaming for like 10
straight years
yeah it's pretty good yeah
I've never been here
not because it may be because he was
always like this we're going to end
my words
[Music]
that's where we need to focus our energy
quick quick what do we got and cancer in
the future we can build together like
spinning the wheel the Maggie
Republicans believe that for them
it's Whispering a little bit I believe
about it I believe America is big enough
for all of us to succeed thank you and
that is the nation we're building the
nation where no one is Left Behind what
about the magazines I
still believe that to be true
I believe the soul is the breadth of
life and the essence of Who We Are
the soul do maggots have souls us
probably not the soul of America what
about the 50 million babies the sacred
proposition that all are crazy in the
image of God why are megas created equal
they all are entitled to be treated with
decency dignity they all deserve justice
and a shot at lives of prosperity and
consequence aside from the Magus and
that democracy democracy must be
defended for democracy makes all these
things possible no it doesn't yeah
folks what country is he talking about
a democratic one
that's fine he's talking about Venezuela
democracy begins and will be preserved
and we the people's habits of the heart
s in our character what about the
immigration optimism that is tested yet
endures
courage that digs deep when we need it
empathy that fuels democracy the
willingness to see each other not as
enemies but as fellow Americans you just
made everybody enemies joke
more democracy it always has been
while we're standing those folks you
hear on the other side there
they're entitled to be outrageous how
unifying this is the mattress then why
are you trying to silence
good manners is nothing they've ever
suffered from
history and Common Sense tell us an
opportunity liberty and justice for all
are most likely to come to pass in a
democracy
we have never fully realized the
aspirations I hope he says democracy
again later but every generation has
opened those doors a little bit wider to
include more people have been excluded
before
Americans
Americans
yell in the background the most powerful
idea in the history of the world his
approval rating
for this country it beats in all our
hearts it unites America
it is the American creed Republicans the
idea that America guarantees that
everyone be treated with dignity
it gives hate no Safe Harbor
it installs in everyone the belief that
no matter where you start in life
there's nothing you can't achieve that's
who we are
that's what we stand for
that's what we believe
and that's precisely what we're doing
opening doors
creating possibilities
focusing on the future and we're only
just beginning
no that was me
close enough I'll always just talking
about it
a guy who's been in Washington for 50
years is only just beginning people are
chatting that he's trying to start a
civil war that's what it sounds and this
work is the work of democracy the work
of this generation is the work of our
time for all time
we can't afford to leave anyone else
hearing Sirens we need everyone to do
their part so speak up are you going to
have internment can't show what's going
to happen
yeah please vote if we do our duty duty
if we do our duty
2022 and Beyond
all right still to come will say we all
of us here we kept the faith we preserve
democracy he's not defeated our word
he's not the guy not the guy he's not
our worst
no it's flat Obama was good that's why
he's yeah the yelling part is a
performance he doesn't feel this Obama
you wished you could think like he did
this guy you just there's nothing is
sacred finally 20 minutes in nothing
more America is that whispering that's
ours yes oh he did it that's who we
truly are
that's what we must always be do you
think you know what he's saying he's not
a politician too long I don't think so
this is who we will be does he want you
said did anybody really come together as
a nation I don't think he knows you ever
heard his speech over the last 40 years
that for the next 200 years watch him
speak and go flip-flop flip flops
United States of America the United
States of America old man
yeah and may God protect all those who
stand watch over our democracy God bless
you all walk the wrong way dude go the
wrong way please I want to win this go
the wrong way if he high-fived the air
you know he thinks he's got it wait
come on come on where's he going
inappropriate contact
[Music]
s
she saved him yeah
his Handler there to take him off stage
the right direction wait he tried
talking it didn't work
[Music]
smart did anybody win
who won nope I think you got the closest
I needed him to go the wrong way if he
walked the wrong way I had sold the
nation Trump starts late and the free
space if he went the wrong way I would
have got it ah boo yeah
I feel like everything he said tonight
was with the caveat except for those
darn Maga Republicans that's pretty much
it is that he says we're the greatest
nation on the earth aside from all the
racist horrible Mega people except for
half the country and we need to unify
aside from all those horrible racist
people let's not unify with them of
course so he's allowed to do this uh the
Hatch Act actually allows the president
the vice president to campaign oh really
yeah it just it I just I'm not entirely
sure that he can use the government
apparatus to do it like the official
White House channel to do a campaign
speech which is what he did this is uh
look man I've been talking about Civil
War for going on like five years now yes
and people called me crazy they said
Tim's nuts it's never gonna happen and I
I I tried explaining to people that what
you see on the ground level with people
who are fighting in the streets is
trickling upwards the culture war is
reaching its way into every branch of
government and it will reach the highest
levels this is what we're seeing now
when the president literally comes out
and says something even more extreme
than Trump said you know I mean and
Trump comes out and he's you know he
smack talks Democrats but smacking
Democrats that's that's politics right
Joe Biden dedicated a speech
prime time to condemn 74 million voters
incredible that's crazy yeah don't
misread that's exactly what he's doing
and this is a guy who campaigned
promising Unity he can't get one
Republican to support any one of his
pieces of legislation and he comes out
and he acts like we're supposed to just
blindly follow his vision only his
vision and if we differ at all we're now
bad people and we need to be condemned
why wasn't he has he ever given a speech
like this about China or about Iran or
about one of the actual threats to this
country or is it well is it just us the
people in this room can I just say
something
I don't think we should paint them as
crazy I think we should as a threat to
our Republic because it's orchestrated
it's Marxist uh rhetoric it's uh on
purpose
there are people behind this that have
been there for decades the globalists
the Klaus Schwabs of the world uh so by
Amy just he's crazy no we've got to come
up with a better strategy to get the
message out in combat this on the other
side on our side Joe Biden when he was
running they said stay alive Joe Biden
we just need your corporeal form that
was an actual article that was written
they were they were running against
Trump yes now they're in a very
difficult position because Biden is he
is anything but charismatic and so this
is their big push because the midterm is
coming up and they desperately need
something but they know they're losing
this it's a scary speech but I gotta be
honest it makes me laugh because they're
they're terrified it's it's that scene
from Starship Troopers when Doogie
Hauser puts his hand on the thing and
then turns around yells it's afraid and
everyone goes like that's exactly what
this is he had to say Maga Republicans
and democracy 50 times because they're
losing I feel like they also just have
nothing to grasp on to except January 6.
like this sounded like it should have
been a Law and Order speech right he's
constantly talking about we need to have
peaceful Americans this that but forget
about the burglaries fentanyl deaths
forget about the fentanyl death forget
about the murders the Asian hate crimes
Going On the Border all of that nah the
Democrats really care about a bit of
trespassing by Grandma on January 6.
That's the Law and Order of the
Democrats because that's all they have
because all the other crime going on is
their fault it's their cities thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check back
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there